مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيتنا للاوضاع
في السودان وفي اخر التطورات السياسيه نفت
الخارجيه السودانيه انباء قبول القوات
المسلحه التفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع اما
على الشق الميداني فقد اتهم الجيش
السوداني مجموعات الدعم السريع بالقصف
العشوائي لمناطق وسط الخرطوم فيما قالت
قوات الدعم السريع بان الجيش مستمر في
الهجوم عليها رغم الهدنه اهلا بكم الى
تغطيه خاصه ومباشره
[موسيقى]
مباشره الى كلمه لوزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه
سوف نعمل على مواصله اجلاء الاشخاص بشتى
سبل لكن لا يمكن ان نطمان قدره على القيام
بذلك نحن ننظر في تقديم الدعم من خلال سبل
اخرى ولذلك قلنا انك وجدا مؤقتا لنا في
بورصه اساسي ولدينا ايضا مسؤولون قنصليون
في بلدان مجاوره هناك سؤال طرح ايضا بشان
عدد الموظفين العاملين
بالسفر عندما بدا الصراع رئيس البعثه
السفير وخارج السودان اليوم
ولكن لدينا ايضا سلسله من
الترتيبات التي سمحت لنقل المسؤوليات الى
المسؤول الثاني في السفاره البريطانيه في
السودان والسفير
الاحداث هناك ايضا ولدينا ايضا وسائل نقوم
باستخدامها مثل طائرات نقل العسكريه
لاجلاء الرعايه اخيرا صحيح تماما
بانه بالتوازي مع عمليات الاجلاء علينا ان
نعمل على الاستقرار الفوري والطويل الامد
لسودان وانهاء هذا الصراع ومنعه من
الامتداد الى البلدان المجاوره وزعزعه
الاستقرار الاقلامي وسنواصل القيامه بذلك
ان اسمي الجهود التي تبذلها وزاره
الخارجيه ويبدلها موظفون وقواتنا المسله
اود ان اشدد على هو غير مقبول بشان
نقلته وسائل الاعلام بشان بعض الموظفين في
تصرفاتهم هذا امر غير مقبول ولا يمكن ان
يستمر بالعوده الى الصراع على الارض عندما
تم الاتفاق على وقف الاطلاق النار فان
العملان العدائيه لم تعود بمنتصف الليل
ونحن نريد
لا يترك سودانيون والاجانب وجهون الاوضاع
المتفاقمه وهل لي ان احث
حضره الوزير على القيام بجهود الضروريه
لتوفير المساعده
وبالنسبه للقضيه التي يثيره
رعايه بريطانيون استطاعوا الوصول الى نقطه
الاجلاء وهناك حاجه لبعض الرعايه فيما
يتعلق بالرعايه الصحيه ولكن هناك بعض
الاشخاص الذين حرموا من
ركوب على متن الطائره تقوم بعمليه الاجلاء
اود ان نطلب من معالي وزير الخارجيه توضيح
هذه المساله والعمل على حل هذه المشكله
كثيرا
الدعم الذي يعبر عن عبرت عنه السيده عضو
مجلس العموم وبطبيعه الحال نحن نسمن ايضا
الموظفين الذين عملوا ضمن ظروف بالغه
التوتر
والتعقيد واود ان اطلب الوسائل الاعلام ان
تتحل بالمسؤوليه في نقل الاخبار وطبعا
اعترف انها واجهت بعض المشكلات وتعقيدات
في حياتها من قبل
وهذا امر يجعلني انظر في توسيع او
الاقتراح الذي قدمته مدرك
انما تم يرميه الى تحسين الاوضاع ولكن
هناك تحد حقيقي بشان توسيع معايير الاشخاص
الذين مؤهلين لل ونحاول ان نكون او نتحلى
بقدر كبير من السخائي ونقدم الدعم للرعايه
البريطانيين
واتفهم
المساله التي اثارتها عضو مجلس العموم
ولكن بتاكيد سوف نقدم الدعم قدر المستطاع
اما بالنسبه
للعدد الاشخاص الذين يمكن اجلائهم وكما
قلت من قبل
اذن استمعنا واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام لوزير
الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليبرلي والذي
قال بان الوضع في السودان قد يتفاقم في
الايام المقبله وبانه لا يضمن القدره على
الاستمرار في اجلاء الرعايه البريطانيه من
السودان وقال باننا ندعم حق الشعب
السوداني في دوله ديمقراطيه مدنيه
ومع استمرار المواجهات وصف الجيش السوداني
الموقف العسكري داخل وخارج الخرطوم
بالمستقر للغايه واضاف الجيش ان الوضع ليس
كذلك بولايه غرب دارفور التي شهدت صراعا
قبليا يجري معالجته بواسطه السلطات
المحليه الجيش اضاف ان قواته متماسكه
وتؤدي دورها في دحر التمرد في كل
الاتجاهات وان الايام المقبله ستشهد
انفراجا كبيرا على الارض على حد وصف
البيان كما اشار الجيش الى ان قوات الدعم
السريع حاولت قصف قياده المنطقه المركزيه
نهر امس لكن قوات الجيش تصدت لهم وكبدتهم
خسائر كبيره بيان الجيش اكد السيطره على
معظم الولايات الا انه وصف الوضع بالخرطوم
بالمعقد بسبب حشد قوات الدعم السريع لمعظم
عناصرها هناك
مبروك مبروك مبروك
مبروك الله
مبروك مبروك
في المقابله تمت قواته الدعم السريع الجيش
بشن هجوم ضد قواتها في معسكر بمنطقه
كافوري في الخرطوم بحري بالطيران
والمدفعيه وقالت في بيانها انه تم التصدي
للهجوم والسيطره على عتاد عسكري وقالت
ايضا ان الجيش يواصل شن هجمات على
معسكراته رغم الهدنه الانسانيه
من جانبها افاده مراسل العربيه بان سلاح
الطيران التابع للجيش السوداني شنغارات
جويه استهدفت مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع
المتواجده في محيط القياده العامه كما
اشار الى استهداف طيران الجيش لقوات الدعم
السريع المتواجده في منطقه صالحه بام
درمان فيما افاد مراسل العربيه عن سماع
دوي اطلاق مضادات ارضيه تابعه للدعم
السريع في محيط القياده العامه بالخرطوم
فقال المدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه لشرق المتوسط الدكتور احمد
المنضري ان الهجمات على البنيه التحتيه
الصحيه في السودان تتصاعد مع سيطره اطراف
النزاع على المستشفيات في الخرطوم وناشد
المنظر عبر تقريره له على تويتر
نشد اطراف النزاع بالاخلاء الفوري لجميع
المرافق الصحيه وعدم اعاقه وظائف الصحه
العامه الحيويه
تحذير اممي من كارثه صحيه في السودان
اربعه وعشرون الف امراه سيلدن دون رعايه
صحيه 50 الف طفل يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه
احدى وستون في المئه من المنشات الصحيه
مغلقه
16% من المرافق الصحيه تمارس عملها
المراكز المخصصه لمنع تفشي الاوبئه توقفت
عن العمل مع امكانيه وقوع اصابات بسبب شرب
مياه غير صالحه تسجيل 16 هجمه على مراكز
المنظمه الطبيه ومقتل ثمانيه اشخاص
الاستيلاء على مختبر طبي يثير مخاوف من
مخاطر بيولوجيه والتلاعب بالعينات
المخزونه
وفي اخر حصيله الاعداد الضحايا جراء
الاشتباكات اكدت نقابه اطباء السودان ان
ثلاثه اطفال لقوا حتفهم في مدينه الاوبيض
بشمال كردوفان نتيجه انفجار قذيفه وقالت
ان عدد القتلى ارتفع الى 3 اشخاص اثرى
استمرار تبادل اطلاق النار المستمر في حين
سجلت النقابه اصابات بلغت
1848 حاله بين المدنيين منذ بدايه الصراع
موضحه ان العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله في هذه الاحصائيه لعدم تمكنها من
الوصول للمستشفيات بسبب صعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مدير الاعلام لدى
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في السودان
جيرمن ميوهو سي جيرمن مرحبا بك معي على
شاشه العربيه بدايه كيف تقيمون الاوضاع
الانسانيه الصحيه في السودان ونحن على
اعتاب دخول الاسبوع الثاني لهذه الازمه
الوضع الانساني في السودان ولا سيما في
العاصمه الخرطوم والكثير من المدن
المتضرره
بالصراع الوضع هو ماساوي
[موسيقى]
للمياه لان المحطات المياه لا تعمل في
الكثير من احياء الخرطوم والناس بحاجه
ايضا للكهرباء
هذه الاحتياجات المهمه جدا للمواطنين
وكذلك للمستشفيات وبالحديث عن المستشفيات
هناك صحفي المستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
والعاملين في القطاع الصحي لا يمكن ان
يتحركوا بامان من منازلهم الى
المستشفيات
ونتيجه لذلك هناك كثير من المستشفيات التي
خرجت عن الخدمه والسبب يعود لانعدام
الموظفين والعاملين والمستلزمات الطبيه
والمياه والكهرباء ان الوضع يصبح اكثر
صعوبه بالنسبه للجميع
وهناك ايضا شحر في النقود والاموال فالناس
ليس لديهم القدره للحصول على النقد من
اجهزه الصرف الالي واغلاق البنوك هذا وضع
يسود ليس فقط في الخرطوم ولكنه موجود ايضا
في الكثير من البلدان بما في ذلك تلك التي
لم تتضرر بالقتال واود ان اشير ايضا الى
ان اسعار
المواد الاساسيه مثل السكر والمواد
الغذائيه هذه الاسعار زادت
بحوالي ثلاثه او اربعه اضعاف وهذا يزيد من
تفاقم الاوضاع بالنسبه للمواطنين ليس هناك
ايضا
الوسيله لاولئك الذين يريدون ان يغادروا
الخرطوم الذي ذهب الى اماكن اخرى فهناك صح
انعدام للوق نرى الاعداد متزايده من الناس
يفرون من المدن المتضرره القتال ويحاولون
الابتعاد عن هذه المدن
وهذا يؤدي الى زياده عدد النازحين في
السودان هذا هو الوضع السائد اليوم
في الكثير من ارجاء السودان ولكن الناس
يعيشون في الخوف لا يعلمون ما يخبئه لهم
المستقبل والى اين سيذهب هذا الصراع طيب
تتحدث عن انعدام الموظفين
ادويه وغيرها من الاحتياجات الاساسيه هل
هذا يعني بانكم لا تستطيعون التحرك لا
تستطيعون المساعده في السودان الان وبانكم
محجمون عن تقديم اي مساعدات بسبب الوضع
الحالي سيد جيرمن
[موسيقى]
المنظمات الانسانيه بالاساس اوقفت اعمالها
في السودان بسبب الوضع الامني لان هذه
المنظمات ليس لديها ضمانات امنيه من طرفي
الصراع
بنسبه
للجنه الدوليه لاساليب الاحمر فقد قررنا
الخروج من العاصمه الخرطوم
ونعمل على بدل كل ما نستطيع لتقديم
مساعدات الانسانيه الملحه لمن يحتاج اليها
في الخرطوم في هذه الاوقات لانه اصبح من
الصعوبه بمكان العمل داخل السودان اود ان
اغتني مع هذه الفرصه ونتحدث على شاشتكم
يدعو كافه الاطراف هو الطرفي صراع
لتيسير عمل المنظمات الانسانيه
وكذلك حركه العاملين في القطاع الصحي حتى
يستطيعوا الوصول الى المستشفيات وتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه كما ادعوهم لتيسير اولئك
الذين يبحثون عن المياه
التوفير الكهرباء هناك حاجه لصيانه محطات
المياه والكهرباء واذا لم يتمكن
السودانيون من
الاعتناء بمتطلبات
الصيانه لمحطات الكهرباء
في ارجاء متعدده من الخرطوم وكذلك المدل
المتضرره بالقتال هل هناك خطر بيولوجي
يحيط بالسودان هذه الايام بعد ان تمت
السيطره المسلحه على مختبر الصحه الوطني
في الخرطوم
بشكل عام انه
مطلب الزامي ان يوفر الجانبان المتقاتلان
الحمايه للمدنيين والمنشات المدنيه وكذلك
توفير الحمايه لكل ما يهدد حياه المدنيين
هذه الرساله التي
نوجهها
جهه جهه اغاثه عالميه ندعو كافه الاطراف
الجيش وكذلك القوات الدعم السعوديه ندعوهم
لحمايه المدنيين والبنى تحتيه المدنيه وكل
ما يمثل خطرا على حياه السكان لكن لم
تجبني سيد جرما عن هذا المختبر البيولوجي
هناك يعني الصحه العالميه تتحدث ايضا بان
هناك
من خلال عبر طبعا مديرها الاقليمي بان هذا
المختبر محتل تحت قوه السلاح وبان هناك
يعني خطر محدق بيولوجي بالسودان بعد
السيطره عليه ماذا لديكم من معلومات حول
هذا الامر
ليست لدينا اي معلومات اضافيه
وافضل عدم الخوض في هذا الامر لاننا في
اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر ليس لدينا
معلومات وافيه حول هذا الامر هل كل
الامدادات الاساسيه المساعدات ايضا حتى
الطبيه
متوقفه تماما في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ولا يمكن نقل اي امدادات او
مساعدات الى داخل العاصمه الخرطوم حتى لو
من الولايات السودانيه يعني القريبه منها
المؤسف هذا هو الوضع السائد الان
واللجنه الدوليه لسليب الاحمر بالاشتراك
مع كافه المنظمات الانسانيه لا سيما جمعيه
الهلال الاحمر السوداني نحن نفكر معا
بالسبل الكفيل بايصال الادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه من خارج السودان الى داخله
ونامل ان تنجح هذه المساعي
رهينه
بالضمانات التي سنحصل عليها وهذا ما سنقوم
به في الايام المقبله لتقديم المساعده
للمستشفيات في الخرطوم والمدن الاخرى
المتضرره من القتال حتى نوفر لهذه
المستشفيات الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه
الهدن الانسانيه لم لم يعني تعتبر بحسب
بعض المراقبين بان هدى هشه لم تصمت تثبيت
الهدنه هنا ربما يكون امرا مستبعدا حتى
يعني توفير الضمانات ربما الامنيه لكم
ولكل طبعا المنظمات الاغاثيه والانسانيه
في السودان او من سياتي ايضا كذلك الى
السودان مستقبلا كيف ستتعاملون مع هذا
الواقع في السودان ماذا لديكم من بدائل
توجد لدينا خيارات لكن هذا يتوقف ايضا على
الطريقه التي يتقاتل بها
الطرفان وكيف سيسهلون عمل المنظمات
الانسانيه التي اوقف الكثير منها انشطتها
في السودان ولكن لا تزال هناك مكاتب
لمنظمات اخرى ويمكن مواصله العمل فيها
ولكن من اجل ذلك نحن نحتاج لضمانات امنيه
من الطرفين المتحاربين هذا هو الخيار
المتاح
والجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع عليهم تيسير عمل المنظمات
الانسانيه حتى يتسنى لنا ان نقدم
المساعدات الطبيه
الملحه لاسيما للجرح الذي لهم في امس
الحاجه للمساعده الان وكذلك
لدعم الوكالات التي توفر الماء والكهرباء
لعامه السكان السوداني ازمه النازحين في
السودان الى اين تتجه حسب تقديراتكم
يعني اولئك الاشخاص الذين نزحوا من
منازلهم اليس كذلك من الخرطوم الى الابيض
من الخرطوم الى عدد من الولايات الاخرى
الكثير من الناس على الطرق ينزحون وهما
يغتنموا فرصه وقف اطلاق النار الحالي
لمغادره المناطق التي يرون انها محفوفه
بالمخاطر اذن هناك من يغادر الخرطوم الى
اماكن اخرى اقل عرضه للقتال هم يغار
يغادرون الخرطوم والمدن التي تشهد قتالا
للذهاب الى اماكن اخرى هناك اشخاص
ينتقلون من الفاشر والجنين في دارفور وقد
تضررت
مدينتان من القتال ويذهبون الى ماكينه
اخرى اذا هناك النازحون داخل السودان كما
تمت اشخاص يلجاون الى بلدان مجاوره الى
مصر وكذلك الى تشاد
والى جمهوريه افريقيا
وجنوب السودان واثيوبيا هذا هو الوضع في
الوقت الحالي علاوه على ذلك
قبل تفجر القتال الحالي
كانت هناك الملايين من النازحين داخل
السودان الملايين من اللاجئين ايضا كانوا
متواجدين داخل السودان وهؤلاء غالبيتهم
كان يحصلون على المساعده من المنظمات
الانسانيه وكمنظمه اغاثه دوليه
فقد تم وقف تقديم المساعده وهذا ما يجعل
حياه الملايين من الناجحين الداخليين
واللاجئين ايضا يجعل هذا اوضاعهم كارثيه
اشكرك شكر جزيل على الانضمام الي من
الخرطوم مدير الاعلام لدى اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في السودان جيرمن ميوهو
[موسيقى]
وقف انا ناس مواطنين سالمين دايرين ياكلوا
لقمه الايش نمشي وين المشكله بقى خطير
علينا
الناس
المساجين وقرايه الصناعيه
اليوم باليوم وانت يا النفرين
منكم بس تهزوا
نفسها خارجيه السودانيه الانباء التي
تتحدث عن تفاوض الجيش والدعم السريع مشيره
الى ان لا صحه لقبول القوات المسلحه
بالتفاوض مع الدعم السريع والا خياره امام
مجموعه الدعم السريع سوى الاستسلام او
الفناء
الخارجيه السودانيه اضافت ان قوات الدعم
السريع مستمره في خروقاتها للهدنه وتعديها
على المدنيين واتخاذهم دروعا بشريه كما
تقوم مجموعه الدعم السريع بالاعتداء على
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه وتعطل عملها
ماذا تضمنت مبادره منظمه الاقليميه
المعنيه بالتنميه في شرق افريقيا ايجاد
تضمنت مقترحات مقتضبه لحل الازمه في
السودان
نصت على تمديد الهدنه الحاليه التي تنتهي
الخميس لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه
ودعوه الطرفين المتحاربين لارسال ممثلين
عنهما او مبعوث عسكري الى جوبا جنوب
السودان لاجراء محادثات بينهما ايجاد طلبت
ارسال مندوبي الطرفين الى جوبا يوم الجمعه
المقبل الساعون للمبادره هم رؤساء جنوب
السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي الجيش اعلن
موافقته المبدئيه على المبادره
وترجيحات بان يكون الفريق شمس الدين كباشي
ممثلا للجيش لا تعليق حتى الان من الدعم
السريع بشان المبادره
هذا ونشد مواطن سوداني طرفي الصراع لوقف
الحربي والاقتتال والعوده الى طاوله
الحوار
اناشد السيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبي ان
ني يوقع نسبه لتعب الشعبي وللمعاناه التي
عاناها الشعب السوداني الذي لم يستحق هذه
المعاناه يا جماعه ارجوكم رد خاص اقعدوا
في طاوله بتاعت حوار وكل خلافات كل لان
خلافاتكم شخصيه جماعه
يا جماعه ربنا ده سبحانه وتعالى هيحاسبكم
على ما فعلتوه في الدنيا وفي الاخره
اغارت مقاتلات الجيش السوداني على مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريعي في الخرطوم وام درمان
وتصدت قوه الدعم السريع لقارات شنها طيران
الجيش على مواقعها في محيط القياده العامه
والقصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم وسمع دبوي
تبادل لاطلاق نار في هذه المناطق ومشطت
قوات الجيش مناطق في محيط قصر الخرطوم
الدولي
اما في بحر شمال الخرطوم جددت الطائرات
الحربيه قصفها اهدافا للدعم السريع في
ضاحيه كافور شرقي بحري وقال الدعم السريع
انه رد على الهجوم وتمكن من احباط الهجوم
على معسكرها وكبد الجيش خسائر كبيره وفي
ام درمان غرب الخرطوم افادت المعلومات
بقصف طيران الجيش منطقه صالحه ومناطق
قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تقع تمركزات الدعم
السريع
ابهرت مقاطع مصوره لاستعداد الحافلات
لعمليات النزوح من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم نتابع
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه المعلنه دعت روسيا
اطراف النزاع الى ضبط النفس الناطقه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخر وفادعت
الى اتخاذ خطوات عاجله لوقف اطلاق النار
وقالت ان الاحداث الماساويه التي يشهدها
السودان تثير قلق موسكو التي تتخذ كافه
الاجراءات اللازمه لضمان سلامه رعاياها
وامكانيه تنفيذ اجراءات الاجلاب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن واشنطن تنضم الينا الصحفيه السودانيه
فاطمه غزالي فاطمه مرحبا بك معي في هذه
الساعه دعيني ابدا معك من اخر تصريحات
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الذي قال بانهم يعملون مع الامم المتحده
لوقف اطلاق النار في السودان وبانهم يسعون
مع الامم المتحده الى تحقيق الانتقال
لحكومه مدنيه في السودان كيف تعلقين على
مجمل هذه التصريحات اولا
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا يا الرحمه لكل الشهداء
الوطن عاجل الشفاء للجرحى وعودا للسودان
في حضن السلام نعم تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي يعني تصوفي يعني التنسيق الذي
تجريه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
الحلفاء ومع المؤسسات الدوليه وهذا امر
متوقع منها تعلم ان الاداره الامريكيه
كثيرا ما تستعين في خططها او سياساتها
الخارجيه بحلفاء في المنطقه او بالمنظمه
الامميه الامم المتحده او مجلس الامن
باعتبار ان لها يعني
مكانه لدى هذه هذه المؤسستين باعتبار انها
الممول الاكبر لهذه المؤسسات كثير من
الاجنده الامريكيه ويعني الرقبات
الامريكيه ايضا كثيرا ما يعني تحول الى
للامم المتحده وتطرح اعمام جلسات مجلس
الامن او جلسات المؤسسه الامميه هذه فهذا
متوقع يعني الحرب المتشعبه المعقده التي
خلفت وضع انسان سيء جدا متوقع ان تعمل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في كل
الاتجاهات ما الذي تملكه واشنطن من اوراق
ضغط على طرفي هذه الازمه حتى تضمن تثبيت
هذه الهدنه حتى وان كانت هدنه هشه خلقت في
اكثر من مكان وفي اكثر من مناسبه
اعتقد ان يعني المساله الوضع الانسان الان
المزري
المتزايد المتفاقم في كل يوم يمكن ان تلوح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا بعقوبات
امميه من مجلس الامن او متحده لحمايه
المدنيين يمكن ايضا هي لديها اوراق يعني
على الرجلين يعني او اوراق ليست بنظيفه او
متسخه اتعلم انهما يعني اداه حرب في
دارفور وقتلاء المدنيين ايضا بقصف الطيران
بمعارك القوات الدعم السريع هذه الاوراق
المتسخه يمكن ايضا ان تكون يعني يعني مصدر
ضبط للطرفين وممكن ان تكون هنالك عقوبات
شخصيه على الرجلين يعني ليس عقوبات يتاثر
بها الشعب السوداني او السوداني يعني كل
هذه يعني طقوس يمكن ان تمارس هنالك قوات
ايضا في جيبوتي انت تعلمي يعني
تزداد يعني يوما بعد يوم هذه المعركه ليست
هينه ولم تحصر في السودان اذا ممتده
اعمدها يعني قد تشمل المنطقه تتوسع
يعني تمس القرن الافريقي غربي افريقيا
قنابل موقوته لاسباب مختلفه منها صراع
المياه منها صراع الاراضي منها صراع
الحركات الارهابيه في المنطقه في قرب
افريقيا وفي القرن الافريقي حتى الصراعات
القبليه يعني مثل ما يحدث مثلا في في
دارفور مثلا
والتي نتابع الان
عاجل اسفل الشاشه ربما يخص شمال دارفور
مراسل العربيه وينقل بان والي شمال دارفور
نشر 150 عربه عسكريه
لتامين مدينه الفاشر وهو السؤال دائما
الذي يتردد هل يمكن ان يخرج هذا الصراع عن
النطاق العاصمي عن الخرطوم يمتد لاكثر من
ولايه لاكثر من منطقه في السودان وتصبح
السودان ساحه
لمواجهات بين طرفي هذه الازمه وربما دخول
اطراف جديده فيها كذلك مسلحه
هذا ما ضللنا نردده يعني منذ اليوم الاول
والثاني للحرب ان هذه الحرب لن تنحصر في
الخرطوم
تمتد الى ولايات بعضها ملتهب يعني ولايه
ولايه دارفور جميعها تعلم انها خارجه من
الحرب ولم تخرج ايضا من الحرب لانه هنالك
حركات لم توقع بعد على السلام مناطق
ماذونه ولايه جنوب كردفان ايضا منطقه
مهزومه بالحروب او ولايه غربي كردفان ايضا
فيها صراعات تعلم قبليه قد يتداخل الصراع
القبلي السياسي
العسكري يعني في هذه الحرب المعقده التي
تزداد تعقيدا يوما بعد يوم لذلك هنالك
ضروره لان تكون هنالك ضغوط اقليميه دوليه
عموميه من اجل وقف اطلاق النار لان انتشار
هذه النار النار هذه تنتشر في الهشيم يعني
تعلم ان السودان يعاني هشاشه امنيه هشاشه
اقتصاديه ظروف انسانيه سيئه لابد ان
تتسارع وتيره المجتمع الدولي لاخماد نار
هذه الحرب والا ستحرق المنطقه باكملها
الاقليم باكمله وتهدد الامن والسلم
الدوليين ابقى معي ابقي معي ساعود اليك
الصحافيه السودانيه فاطمه غزالي من
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن اذا اغارت
مقاتلات الجيش السوداني على مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم وام درمان وتصدت
قوات الدعم السريع لغارات شنها طيران
الجيش على مواقعها في محيط القياده العامه
والقصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم وسمع دوي تبادل
لاطلاق نار في هذه المناطق ومشطت قوات
الجيش مناطق في محيط مطار الخرطوم الدولي
وفي بحر شمال الخرطوم جددت الطائرات
الحربيه قصفها اهدافا للدعم السريع في
ضاحيه كافوري شرقي بحري وقال الدعم السريع
انه رد على الهجوم وتمكن من احباط الهجوم
على معسكرها وكبد الجيش خسائر كبيره وفي
ام درمان غرب الخرطوم افادت المعلومات
بقصف طيران الجيش منطقه صالحه ومناطق
قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تقع تمركزات الدعم
السريع
اكد وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس
كليفرلي ان بلاده لديها ما يكفي من
القدرات اللازمه لاجلاء الرعايه من
السودان في ظل وجود هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار
حان الوقت للتحرك لدينا الطائرات والقدرات
وايضا هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار لذلك نقول
للناس اذا كنتم تريدون الحصول على دعمنا
للسفر خارج السودان فافعلوا ذلك الان
يمكننا تسهيل خروجكم ربما سيقرر بعض
الاشخاص لاسباب خاصه البقاء حتى عندما يتم
وقف اطلاق النار لكننا نقول هناك رحلات
جويه واذا كنت ترغب في السفر فهذا هو افضل
وقت للقيام بذلك
اما في بورتسودان فيستمر توافد مئات رعايه
مختلف الجنسيات من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم شرقا وذلك بغرض استكمال اجراءات
اجلائهم خارج البلاد حيث ادى ذلك لاكتضاض
المئات من طالبي اللجوء داخل مراكز تنسيق
اجراءات مغادره بمدينه بورتسودان كما تعمل
اللجان الاشراف السودانيه بالتنسيق مع
سفارات الدول الاجنبيه على جمع وحصر
المغادرين والتاكد من بياناتهم
وصلنا بصعوبه صعوبه لا يعني ما تنوصف يعني
قاعد نمشي على القتله وصلنا هنا لكن ما في
يعني عشره يوم مرت علينا يمكن اكلين عيشه
واحده الاف او عشان ما يكون في مبالغه
مئات من السوريين موجودين في الخرطوم ما
قادرين يتحركوا اولا انعدام الامان ثانيا
الغلاء الموجود في بالنسبه للترحيل ثالثا
زي ما قلنا الشوارع ما كلها امنه يعني
خادم الحرمين الشريفين والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الناس لكن نطلب رجاء خاص من
برهان من حمدتي الله يهديكم ربنا يهديكم
يعني شعب السوداني منتهي شعب سوداني في
شارع الجاليات في الشارع الناس يعني يعني
ما ممكن نفرين يتشاكلوا يضيعوا الناس في
النص
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن تنفيذه
عمليات اجلاء جديده مؤكده ان عمليات
الاجلاء شملت مواطنين فرنسيين وكذلك
مواطنين من بريطانيا والولايات المتحده
وكندا واثيوبيا وهولندا وايطاليا والسويد
كما اكدت انها قامت حتى الان باجلاء
936 شخصا
في الاردن اجت الطائرات تابعه لسلاح الجو
الملكي الاردني 70 شخصا من المواطنين
وجنسيات عربيه واجنبيه من الهيئات
الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات الدوليه واكد
الناطق باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه سنان
المجالي ان بلده سيستمر بتقديم يد العون
للدول الصديقه وللرعايه الاردنيين في
السودان مما لديهم الرغبه في الخروج من
الاراضي السودانيه
يعني رحله كانت من الخرطوم لابورت سودان
عبر الامم المتحده اخذت تقريبا اربعين
ساعه بس الحمد لله انه يعني المملكه
الاردنيه يعني المبادره اللي عملوها
بيشكروا عليها رحله من السودان من داخل
السودان صراحه كان في كثير مخاطر تعرضنا
لها لكن الحمد لله تيسرت والله كان الوضع
كتير صعب صعب كتير كتير كتير يعني
فجاه صارت المشاكل وضرب يعني قطعه
الكهرباء والمي
وعلينا كتير
[موسيقى]
انا ناس مواطنين سالمين دايرين ياكلوا
لقمه ايش نمشي وين المشكله بقى خطير علينا
كل حاجه يعني الناس
المساكين
اليوم باليوم وانت يا الن
فرين
ومعنا من معبر ارجينا على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان احمد
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه كيف تبدو
الصوره من حولك في هذا المعبر كثافه
الحافلات ايضا من حولك هتزادت
نايف تح للمشاهدين بالفعل كما ذكرت هناك
يعني استمرار وتفاوت في الاعداد من
القادمين الى السودان ربما بحسب بعض
الاحصائيات بان هذا المال كذا او هذا
المعبر يشهد اكبر نسبه اقبال من القادمين
من السودان الايام الاخيره والساعات
الاخيره الكثير من الذين ياتون من
السودانيين انفسهم يعني هناك بالفعل نسب
من المصريين ونسب من الاجانب كنت تتحدث
منهم البعض يعني الارقام الاحصائيات
الدقيقه تظهر مع نهايه هذا اليوم المشهد
معتاد هناك الحافلات التي تنتظرهم وتتجه
بهم الى اسوان او الى القاهره ربما كان
المشهد الابرز او الحديث الابرز مع من كنت
اتحدث معهم او اغلب
او اغلب من كنت اتحدث معهم هي فكره
الموكوس لفتره طويله جدا داخل المعبر سواء
من الجانب السوداني او داخل المعبر المصري
حتى الخروج وبالتالي ربما كانت هذه هي
النقطه التي كانت محل تعليق ولكن هذه
النقطه من جانبها السلطات المصريه اوضحت
بان هذا المعبر ربما يعني لم يكن هذا
المعبر الذي تم انشاؤه عام 2016 لم يكن
مخصص لان يكون مكانا لتدفق عدد كبير من
المواطنين هو في البدايه وفي النهايه كان
من المخصص ان يكون معبر للشاحنات والبضائع
ومن ثم كان هذا الاندفاع الكبير من
النازحين الذين يقدرون بالالاف كان سببا
بالاضافه ايضا الى اهميه ان يكون هناك
تدقيق امني اللقط الذي خلق قد اثير من بعض
حول عدم حصول تاشيره هذه
التاشيره مسبقه التاشيرات المسبقه كانت
مطلوبه بين 18 وال 50 من هم اصغر ومن هم
اكبر هم فقط
المستثنون من هذه العبور عمليات التدقيق
التفتيش الكشف عن الصحف الجنائيه لضمان
عدم دخول عناصر ارهابيه متسدله كل هذه
العناصر والعوامل ربما هي التي كانت سببا
في هذا التاخير الكبير الذي كان محل شيك
على الجانب الاخر ايضا هناك من كان ينتظر
من السودانيين الذين يرغبون في العوده الى
السودان على الجانب الاخر والذين ايضا
انتظروا لفتره الساعات امتدت الى ايام حيث
ان لوجستيات الانتقال داخل هذا المعبر لها
علاقه بالحافلات وعمليه الحافلات التي
تنتقل من الجانب السوداني الى الجانب
المصري لتقوم بنقل السودانيين المنتظرين
هنا للعوده بهم مره اخرى الى داخل حدود
السودان وهو ما يعني تحرك بعض الشيء خلال
الساعات الاخيره حتى الان هناك يعني
اهتمام كبير جدا من السلطات المصريه في
تقديم ربما العون بقدر المستطاع الى
السودانيين القادمين سواء اذا تحدثنا عن
سيارات اسعاف او هلال احمر داخل المعبر
لتقديما مساعدات الطبيه خصوصا مع ساعات
الارهاق مع رحلات القدوم وايضا الموكوس
داخل هذا المعبر ايضا ايضا كان هناك قرار
بالقطارات توفير عدد اكثر من القطارات
لمساعده السودانيين الذين يتجهون من اسوان
اقرب مدينه من هنا الى العاصمه القاهره كل
هذه الامور كانت محل اهتمام خلال الساعات
الماضيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه الصوره
التي تنقلها لنا منذ الصباح وحتى هذه
الساعه من معبر الارجين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد
عثمان
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه
2016 لنقل البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه
850 كيلومترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه
الاف وخمسمائه مسافر يوميا واكثر من
ثلاثمائه شاحنه بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين
من اشتباكات السودان عبر منه الالاف من
السودانيين والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد
اجتياز المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه
اسوان الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه
بالمتاعب تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من
الخرطوم ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان
ونظرا لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح
للسودانيين بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
بعد نزوح تظل لحظات الرعب عالقه في
الاذهان هذا هو حال عائله سودانيه هربت من
النزاع الى مصر كاميرا العربيه وثقت لحظات
خوف عاشتها اسره سودانيه تحت عزيزي الرصاص
ان تعود الى منزلك مطمئنا انك ستجد اسرتك
في امان هذا يساوي الكثير عند عبد اللطيف
حامد المقيم في مصر منذ سنوات بعد ان كاد
القلق يفتك به خوفا على اسرته التي كانت
تحاول الهروب من الاشتباكات الدائره في
السودان ووصلت بسلام الى مصر منذ ثلاثه
ايام انا كنت جالك جدا وكنت متابعا
بالتليفون عبر التلفونات وعبر الواتساب
لحظه انه الاتصال اتقطع بيني وبينه بكون
دايما خايف وعايش في رعب شديد انه البلد
ما امنه يعني حتى لحد الحمد لله لحد ما
وصلوا اسطوان وكنت متابعهم خطوه بخطوه
وكلمه بكلمه قرار الخروج من كسلا ومن
السودان صوب مصر اتخذته السيده سوسن
وابنتها ريما خوفا على اولادهما قبل الحرب
كانت صعبه وهسه زاد الوضع سوق عندنا العيش
في المخابز ما في الغاز ما في كهرباء ما
في مويه ما في يعني الحياه انعدمت تماما
يعني في اي لحظه نحن ممكن نضيع اولادي
يضيع مني اما الرحله الطويله التي استغرقت
ثلاثه ايام فكانت خليطا من المشقه والخوف
في الطريق ماذا
خفيفه الاولاد عايزين
ياكلوا عايزين يشربوا عايزين يناموا
مرتاحين فهمته وبعدين صوت النار العلب
يخافوا في الايام العاديه غير الحرب كان
في نهر
يعني انت بتيجي ماشي بالعربيه فين في في
ناس بيموت وكده في الطريق يعني هسه احنا
لما جاي قلبنا في يدنا في المرعب
يعني
في الشوارع ويجر الصاص والباباني بتوعه
والحريق لا نحن محتاجين دكتور نفساني
والله العظيم يعني انا ما اعرف انا ما
قريت الملف لكن الوضع من
جوه اخر يعني مستحيل انك تشوف يعني انت في
لحظه وانت قاعد في بيتك مطمئن فجاه تلقى
نفسك جيت لاجئ اخيرا تم لم شمل الاسره بعد
عناء تركوه وراء ظهورهم مع ما تركوه من
امتعه في بيتهم المغلق في كسلا فهم جاؤوا
باقل القليل من الملابس ويشعرون بعدم
الثقه في ان محنتهم ستنتهي قريبا تامر
نصرت العربيه القاهره
عبر الاهالي في مدينه ام درمان عن مخاوف
حقيقيه من استمرار عمليات السلبي والنهب
بسبب الاقتتال الدائري بين قوات الجيش
والدعم السريع واظهرت لقطاته فيديو خاصه
بالعربيه مشاهد تظهر اغلاق المحلات
التجاريه في الاسواق الرئيسيه مع اعاده
فتح عدد قليل منها وسط حذر شديد فيما
يطالب الاهالي الحكومه بتوفير الحمايه
اللازمه وتامين حياه السكان في ام درمان
والخرطوم ووقف اعمال العنف
شغالين شغل مره كسروا الدكاكين
والشوا
كثير
كلها مقفله العالميه
لكن الوضع سيء سيء للدرجه بعيده خلاص في
السوق
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه عن دعمها
الكامل لانهاء العنف في السودان والحد منه
حيث اكدت مسؤوله بالوزاره انها بحثت مع
قائد الجيش الوطني الليبي خليفه حفتر
ضروره منع الجهات الخارجيه ومن بينها
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه من زعزعه استقرار
ليبيا او جيرانها بمن فيهم السودان
عد الى واشنطن والى ضيفه من هناك الصحفيه
السودانيه فاطمه غزالي سيده فاطمه مرحبا
بك معي مره اخرى كنت اسال قبل قليل عن
الاوراق التي تملكها واشنطن
للدفع بالطرفي هذه الازمه الى التسويه او
على الاقل الى تثبيت قدره وقف اطلاق النار
لكن اليس الموقف الانساني اليوم
المتردي والصعب في السودان بين المدنيين
هو اهم هذه الاوراق التي يجب ان يتم الضغط
بها
نعم اعتقد ان الوضع الانساني استهداف
المدنيين ايضا من الاوراق الكبيره التي
يمكن الضغط يعني بها لانها ايضا هذه تمثل
فروقات للقانون الدولي والقانون الانساني
كما تعلم يعني يمكن ان يتهم
القياديان بانهما ارتكبها جرائم حرب في او
جرائم ضد الانسانيه لان القصف بالطيران
ايضا انتهاك للقانون الدولي محاوله جعل
المدنيين دروع بشريه بالتواجد والتقلقل في
وسطهم ايضا هي تعتبر من كرائم ضد
الانسانيه واضح ان الملف الانساني سيفرض
نفسه على الواقع وعلى المشهد كما فرضوه من
يعني من قبل في مناطق حروبات اخرى في
دارفور ايضا يعني الملف الانساني هو الذي
يعني ضغط على المنظومه الدوليه في ان
تستجيب وتصدر قرارات وترسل محققين ولجنه
تحقيق وخبراء
وجاءت يعني ممثلين
يعني الممثلين للامم المتحده
السودان تحت قرارات ومقرر خاص في السودان
هذا السيناريو يمكن ان يتكرر بهذه الازمه
الانسانيه وباستهداف المدنيين الذي ما زال
مستمرا يعني طيب كانت يعني قبل قليل
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر تقول بان
المشافي في السودان تفتقر للاحتياجات
الاساسيه وبان الوضع الصحي يتدهور اكثر
فاكثر هذا الكلام ليس فقط لهم ايضا حتى
للصحه العالميه فما هي البدائل على الاقل
الموجوده اليوم في السودان والتي يمكن
التعامل فيها مع هذا الواقع المتردي صحيا
في السودان السيده فاطمه
استنى يعني هنالك جهود صحيح من محليين او
من شباب كوادر اللجان المقاومه لكن ليس
لديهم يعني الامكانيات او توفير يمكن
لديهم الاستعداد القوى البشريه للمساعده
للمساهمه للنقل لاتصالات ومعرفه من هو
المريض الذي يحتاج الى الغداء ولكن من اين
له ان ياتي يعني ياتوا بهؤلاء بالادويه او
يعني بالمعينات الطبيه هذه يعني معادله في
تقدير صفريه يعني ما لم تكون هنالك تدخلات
من المنظمات الدوليه المعنيه بالصحه يعني
ظل الجميع مكتوب فيه الايادي وانت يعني
تعلم ان المستشفيات الان تسير من
المستشفيات خرجت حتى خارج الخدمه يعني
هنالك ايضا مستشفى يعني التوليد كانت يعني
تعرض لانقطاع
للكهرباء هنالك مستشفيات كثيره خرجت من
الخدمه
سيريدون دون عنايه او رعايه طبيه هنالك من
غاده بسب
ب وجود يعني
ايضا المرضى يعني منه من غادر لانه اصبحت
بيئه غير صالحه يعني مكان للتشافي ولكن
اصبح مصدر ايضا
يعني للاوبئه والامراض
ايضا الوضع الانساني كيف تناولته جلسه
مجلس الامن وامام سيده فاطمه كيف رقبتي
تناول الوضع الانساني هناك باختصار
وركزت عليه وتحدثت عنه ولكن هذا بالنسبه
لي ليس كافيا الشيء المطلوب ان تكون هنالك
مساعدات من المنظمات الامميه
التي تعنى بالصحه بما ان هنالك مقدره على
يعني
لطيران ياتي الى منطقه بورسودان لنقل
الاجلاء الاجانب والدبلوماسيين يمكن ان
ايضا الامم المتحده ان تستخدم او تستعين
بدول لجلبه المعينات الطبيه يعني ليس بامر
صعب او يعني مستحيل اشكرك جزير الشكر من
واشنطن الصحفيه السودانيه فاطمه غزالي
اما من ناحيه الغرب شهيده الحدود التشاديه
السودانيه وصول حوالي 20 الف لاجئ سوداني
منذ اندلاع الحرب هذه الصور رصدت الاوضاع
الانسانيه الصعبه التي يعيشها السودانيون
من
بينهم نساء واطفال
[موسيقى]
التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب سعر الباص كله
خمسه مقاعد لكن
مليار وخمسين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات